get your eyes checked because what
you're about to see is probably illegal
in your state is their center
pornography that is not a medical
question Amazon is back with its latest
original starring Legolas in that girl
from Suicide Squad and I'm here to take
a deep dive into its ending and what it
could mean for season two so grab
yourself a drink and watch out for dark
Asher's because we're taking a trip to
Carnival row eight titled the gloaming
an old English word for Twilight or dusk
starts with quill the puck undertaking a
mission to prove himself to the hidden
one after being fired in Episode two for
failing to protect Absalom breaks pierce
son Jonah from being kidnapped quill is
forced to the streets eating from the
garbage when he's approached by a monk
that warships the hidden one he hands
him a copy of their holy book known as
the ciphers which contains stories that
quills mother used to read to him as a
child the cipher symbol found on the
book here can also be found to the
entrance of their holy place meanwhile
vignettes Tomas attempts to escape jail
but is stopped by racists sergeant
zombie she was put there after breaking
into the burgh Museum which featured an
exhibition on the treasures of Tiernan
ah in Episode three we get a glimpse of
the holy library which ben protects only
to find that it has been disassembled
piece by piece to be shown as some
novelty to the human folk who disdained
fake culture it was brought across the
sea timber by Tim in an equally dire
predicament is Rycroft ilustrate burg
inspector in charge of solving a slew of
mysterious murders that have been
plaguing the city he's been held captive
by Chancellor break spear after he was
framed for the murder of Ashlyn corral
laughs a woman who was killed at the end
of episode one it turns out break spear
had an affair with Ashland years ago one
which was held secret since human and
Fae relationships are looked down upon
when his father found out about this
tryst he threatened to kill her unless
break spear called it off Ashland wanted
to meet one last time to tell him
something important but as to not put
her life in danger he never showed up as
he says to Philo I was a coward that
important thing she was to tell him she
was pregnant and with the revelation
that Ashland was Philo's mother that
makes breaks
his biological father it's also ironic
that both breaks beer and Philo left the
women they love for their quote unquote
own safety but as brakes Pierre said it
was really cowardice this is a mistake
Philo won't make again at the end of the
season where he embraces his half-blood
Fey roots and ventures to carnival Row
to be with VIN speaking of leaving women
for their own safety
Ferguson mr. Agrius get in a row over
our Grace's affair with image and spurn
rose as a graces servant Fergus has
heard through the grapevine that members
of the community have been suspicious of
their recent let's just say closeness to
protect her grace must call things off
and he does it in quite possibly the
worst way ever
the truth is imagine is that you are a
callow and graceless lover and yesterday
was utterly forgettable but Imogen sees
through this Sherrod willing to pay the
price for love but can a gray us first
unless you Tevan I come to the fore of
course imagens pervy brother is watching
through the window piety breaks beer
confronts her son about his affair with
Sophie longer bein their family's
political rival such an affair could
jeopardize their family's reputation and
everything piety has worked for all
these years that girls is twice as
dangerous as anything on the read but
Jonah isn't budging he's in love not
just with Sophie but her lust for power
the only way pi D can sway Jonah is by
telling him the truth that Sophie is his
sister you see years ago Ritter longer
Bain was a rival for pie Dee's affection
and they ended up having a child Jonah
but piety left longer Bain for break
spear likely because of a prophecy she
was given this prophecy stated that she
would marry a great man that man being
Absalon break spear but his son would be
even greater what she didn't know is
that son wasn't Jonah rather Philo
here's where things get a little more
complicated the thing that triggered the
events of Carnival Row was a letter
written to piety a letter allegedly from
the mother of break Spears bastard son
to extort break spear for money she
would go to the papers and tell them the
current Chancellor had a half-blood son
unless she was paid of course
this letter wasn't written by ashlynn
Quirrell but rather Sofie longer Bane in
an attempt to cause chaos why did you do
this because chaos creates opportunity
for what for us
southeast quest for power is achieved
through this chaos with Jonah she talks
about how only through chaos can new
powers arise chaos it's the great hope
of those in the shadows chaos for men
like your father creates opportunity for
people like you and me regimes fool old
worlds burn and we decide one rises from
the ashes this is similar to the work of
Naomi Klein who argues in her book the
Shock Doctrine that the exploitation of
national crises such as an economic
collapse a natural disaster or let's say
political assassination can be used to
push through controversial policies
while citizens are too emotionally and
physically distracted by these things to
mount an effective resistance but this
revelation that break spear had another
son call Spidey's prophecy into question
what if it wasn't Jonah who would rise
to greatness rather this bastard this
results in PI deconstructing a dark
Asher to do her bidding in an attempt to
find out who this bastard really is
because she doesn't know who this child
is she must kill those who knew him to
obtain their livers livers in the Dark
Carnival universe contains secrets and
by eating them you can unlock them this
is why she sends the dark asher after
those close to Philo first his mother
then to the head of the orphanage
Marauders the man who clipped his wings
as a child and finally the her aspects
by killing these people who knew Philo
she can get closer to finding out his
identity killing him once and for all so
that she can be at ease that her
prophecy that Jonah will achieve
greatness the dark asher the creature
that was used to do her bidding was
constructed by a patchwork of corpses as
meme assassin says in Episode four
there's a strange power in the joining
of unlike things this joining of unlike
things is a common theme throughout the
season Philo himself is half human and
half
Faye he initially surmises that the
monster plaguing the burg is a dark
Asher and consults the horrific says to
the possibility of such a beast you see
the dark Asher is believed to be a myth
so Philo asks this which type character
gifted in potions and necromancy if such
a creature is possible and to his
surprise it is the her epic chops it to
pieces but it remains alive a dark Asher
is never truly killed until its master
is this is seen in the final
confrontation between PI D and Philo
where he beheads the creature only for
it to reattach its head later on PI D
had learned from the heroics how to
conjure such a creature the heretics had
been an integral part of parties family
for years and there's even a picture of
them together when PI D was a child when
the heretics is killed by PI DS dark
Asher the heretics drinks a special
potion which temporarily suspends her in
the gloaming a world that is between day
and night breath and silence before her
death she's able to tell Philo of piety
z' dark plans but back to them being
story quill attempts to assassinate
Chancellor break spear but is
unsuccessful expect to see his character
feature more prominently in season 2
he'll likely be used by the humans to
justify greater restrictions on the Fae
as is evidenced by them being rounded up
at the end of the season but with plenty
of face latch scritch sympathizers about
I wouldn't be surprised if quill finds a
way out of jail
PI D upon learning that her husband
knows the identity of his bastard son
kills him in order to find out who it is
by performing the ritual on his liver
and with the notice to release vin in
his undergarments Heidi decides to
exploit Philo's greatest weakness his
love for vin and get him to come to her
meanwhile as ro holds a gray us and
Imogen at gunpoint after he finds out
that they've been sleeping together
they're able to turn the tables but a
graceless assault on Ezra will assuredly
result in his arrest
so Imogen and Agrius decide to run from
burg for good and just in the nick of
time
the captain of the ship alerts them that
they've been notified to return to port
and order a grass does not obey so next
season will either a see them arrested
by the authorities or b which i think is
more plausible start a new somewhere
else where they will eventually aid in
the freeing of the Fae in car
Roah we also see Ezra who doesn't look
all too pleased about what's just
happened so he'll likely be on the hunt
for a grass and his sister
Fievel confront Spidey and battles her
dark Ashur and when things look like all
his lost for him vin comes to save the
day by killing piety with her death the
dark Asher dies as well they embrace but
this is just the start of their problems
they attempt to leave the Berg but are
stopped by the authorities after a new
law sequestering all fate to the ro has
been passed in lieu of the recent
assassination of Chancellor breaks beer
then is sent to the row and Philo goes
with her we even witnessed the murder of
Vince friend flurry which will
undoubtedly cause Carnival ro to be a
powder cake going into season two but
more concerning is the joining of Sophie
and Jonah the Chancellor and official
opposition who are secretly in cahoots
with one another it's ironic to see a
man whose father stood up for Fay Wray
--tz-- now spearheading their
destruction today we have a common enemy
and we must found this one if we ought
to prevail carnival Row is a damning
critique of how society today is still
fueled by racism segregation and fear of
the other carnival row becoming its own
detainment camp at the end of the season
it's clear that creators are drawing
from real-life instances season 2 has
been greenlit so expect to see VIN and
Philo's relationship continue to
flourish as they deal with the seemingly
insurmountable enemy that is the burgh
under the rule of Jonah and Sofie the
black Ravens will surely lash out at
being cooped up the death of flurry will
have some consequences - in rallying the
Faye and if things continue to get worse
an uprising might be in store for next
season we also haven't heard from the
pact in a bit so they could always come
into play to shake things up that's it
for my breakdown of season 1 of carnival
row I want to hear your thoughts about
the season in the comments below and
make sure to LIKE and subscribe with the
bell on you can follow me on twitter at
things story whitey and until next time
remember daddy loves you very much